who is this is your friend of yours or
why you saying like he's gay insulting
but you guys are the same gender that's
your partner if he doesn't identify as a
gender as your partner how do you
identify sir my bad I says sir I just
assume drip from masculinity and you're
just clearly such a man you know what I
mean that's not gonna make him feel good
about himself this ain't doing it
y'all are in love y'all
been together for how long
let's do a little legality math here
how are you right now
you have to go two grades down to hit it
down off of somebody oh one great she
cut off she's an October Birthday or
Whatever right
now I see weird okay you think I give a
when your birthday is
birthdays
oh I like that you defended her that's a
good man he groomed her a little bit but
that only
all right